Ehrenkompanie essen
zur Übernahme der Insignien der
heeresrundoffiziersakademie das ganze
Rechtsschutz
[Musik]
das ganze
habt acht
ehrenkomponie
zur Meldung an die Frau Bundesministerin
das ganze recht schaut
vor Bundesministerin Oberst halber
meldet die Militärmusik des
Militärkommandos Oberösterreich die
Insignien sowie die zweite Garde
komponie der Garde die insignen der
Heeres und offiziersakademie sowie den
ausmusterungsjahrgang 2023 gegliedert in
Direktionen und Brigaden zur feierlichen
Übernahme des unprofiziers Chor des
Bundesheeres am Tag der Wachtmeister
angetreten
mit dem Festakt beginnen
[Musik]
Frau Bundesministerin obersthalber
meldet sich ab
[Musik]
das ganze
habt acht
jährige
Flagge hissen
zur Flag Parade das ganze
[Musik]
hat
[Applaus]
Parade
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
wie in der ersten Information
angekündigt werden Sie in Kürze eine
Premiere zum Heurigen Tag der
Wachtmeister erleben über den Stadtplatz
von Enns werden in Kürze 4
Transporthubschrauber agustavel 212 und
eine Transportmaschine
C130 Hercules den Luftraum überfliegen
die Flieger befinden sich derzeit noch
im Bereitstellung und werden gegen 11
Uhr 10 über uns zu sehen und zu hören
sein
für Information die Flieger werden aus
Richtung Süden kommen und den Stadtplatz
Richtung Norden überfliegen wenn sie
kurz in meine Richtung schauen die
Richtung die ich zeige entlang der
Wiener Straße und dort werden die
Flieger kommen und dann gerade über den
Stadtplatz
diese Transportmaschine sind Teil des
Kommandos Luftunterstützung welches in
Hörsching am Fliegerhorst Vogler
disloziert ist
sie dienen primär Transportzwecken und
anderen werden die Fallschirmspringer
aus der C130 Herkules abgesetzt weiters
wird die agustavellen auch im Rahmen von
lösch-
sie werden die Flugzeuge bzw das
Flugzeug und die Hubschrauber in Kürze
hören das rotorengeräusch ist nicht
überhörbar
meldet sich zum Überflug an wenn sich
der ausbusserung der Wachtmeister des
Jahrgangs Zuhörer lippers was kann man
da Luft Unterstützung
jedes Ziel soll das
ein herzliches Dankeschön an unsere
Luftstreitkräfte für diese Einlage und
die großbotschaft und um in der
pilotensprache zu bleiben we wish you
blue skies and happy landings
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Zuseherinnen und Zuseher beim Livestream
es ist für uns als
Ausbildungseinrichtung und vor allem für
die angetretenen jungen Wachtmeister ein
besonderes Zeichen von Wertschätzung
heute eine so große Anzahl hochrangiger
ehren- und Festgäste begrüßen zu dürfen
ich freue mich am Tag der Wachtmeister
diese schöne und zugleich ehrenvolle
Aufgabe wahrnehmen zu dürfen
an der Spitze aller hier anwesenden
Vertreter aus Politik Gesellschaft und
Militär darf ich mit besonderem Respekt
und auch Dankbarkeit unsere Frau
Bundesministerin für Landesverteidigung
Frau Magister
für die hohe Geistlichkeit ist es mir
eine Ehre stellvertretend für alle
Glaubensgemeinschaften Herrn Militär
Generalvikar Magister Peter Pabst ein
herzliches Grüß Gott zu sagen
[Musik]
mit Hochachtung darf ich als militärisch
höchst Anwesenden den Chef des
Generalstabs Herrn general Magister
Rudolf Striedinger zum heutigen Tag der
Wachtmeister begrüßen
die Austrian Armee Enzio Academy
maintains and develops corporations
drangigen Persönlichkeiten aus
verschiedenen Bereichen unseres
Zusammenlebens macht es mir unmöglich
jeden von ihnen einzeln zu begrüßen
daher erlaube ich mir die folgenden
Damen und Herren
stellvertretend und in einem Block hier
in Enns begrüßen zu dürfen ich biete sie
alle den Applaus für den Schluss dafür
dann aber umso kräftiger aufzusparen
mit Hochachtung und Respekt begrüße ich
in Vertretung des Landeshauptmanns von
Oberösterreich Herrn
Landtagsabgeordneten Wolfgang Stanek
in den beiden vergangenen Jahren mussten
wir Pandemie bedingt den Festakt in der
Kaserne durchführen
umso mehr freuen wir uns heute wieder in
der Öffentlichkeit sein zu können
unser Dank gilt in diesem Zusammenhang
und darüber hinaus und daher möchte auch
besonders begrüßen den Bürgermeister der
Stadt Enns und Partner der Heeres
unteroffiziersakademie ein Christian
in Vertretung der parlamentarischen
bundesheer-
ich begrüße den Leiter der
Generaldirektion präsidiale in der
Zentralstelle ihren Sektionschef Hofrat
Dr Schavan
in unserer Mitte darf ich begrüßen den
Vorsitzenden des zentralen
der Bundesheer Gewerkschaft Herrn
Abteilungsleiter Magister Walter Hirsch
für die Direktion Ausbildung den
ausbildungschef und Kommandanten der
Landesverteidigungsakademie ein
Generalleutnant Magister
und den stellvertretenden
überleitungsverantwortlichen und
bestellten direktionsleiter im BMV
für die Direktion Verteidigungspolitik
und internationale Beziehungen Herrn
Brigadier Magister dr Peter vorhofer
für die Direktion Kommunikation Herr
ministralrat mag
für die Direktion Personal Herr
ministralrat Dr Hauser
und für die Direktion Rüstung ein
Generalmajor magic
stellvertretend für die
überleitungsverantwortlichen
direktionsleiter im Generalstab für die
Direktion IKD und Cyber ein
generalmangister caponig
und den kommando_lo
UIs Magister Wagner und den kommando_lo
ich begrüße den tollen der
militär-vereinigung Wien Herrn Oberst im
Generalstab Julian suar und alle
Anwesenden militärischen
stellvertretend für alle Anwesenden
Militärkommandanten darf ich mit Freude
unseren Militärkommandanten wir haben
Magister Mur begrüßen
die Mitarbeiter unseres Bundesheeres
stellen eine entscheidende wenn ich die
wichtigste Ressource da
her freut es uns besonders die Leiterin
der Abteilung allgemeine Personal
Angelegenheiten Frau ministralrätin
magdeckers und den Leiter der Abteilung
konkrete Personaladministration Herr
ministralrat Magister laschal
stellvertretend für alle
Abteilungsleiter in der Zentralstelle zu
begrüßen
für alle private Kommandanten darf ich
zwei unserer militärischen Nachbarn den
Kommandanten der vierten
Panzergrenadierbrigade Herren-
[Musik]
ich begrüße den Präsidenten der
österreichischen Offiziersgesellschaft
Herrn Brigadier Magister Erich sibulka
und dem Präsidenten der österreichischen
undoffiziers Gesellschaft und Partner
der huak ja viel zu Leutnant Auinger und
mit ihnen alle Präsidenten und
Funktionsträger in der
Bundesorganisation und den Landesstellen
für alle Kommandanten der Waffengattung
Schulen den Kommandanten der
heereslogistikschule Herren
für die Kommandanten der Verbände der
Präsenz und militorganisation darf ich
begrüßen die Kommandantin des
versorgungsregiments 1 Frau
Oberstleutnant Magistra Jasmin großler
und den
kommandantenon Oberösterreichs
stellvertretend für alle
traditionsverbände den Kommandanten des
dragonarregiments
in Tradition Johann Marian Eckert
es ist uns ein besonderes Anliegen die
Angehörigen der Damen und Herren
Wachtmeister des ausrüstungs Jahrgangs
2023 zu begrüßen wir freuen uns sehr
dass sie so teuer endlich wieder möglich
ist mit Ihnen diesen besonderen Tag
gemeinsam und in der Öffentlichkeit
feiern zu dürfen
nicht zuletzt möchte ich aber sie
geschätzte Absolventen des
jahrgangszugsführer Franz Lippert in der
Garnisonsstadt ihre militärischen Heimat
der heeresunteroffiziersakademie ganz
besonders begrüßen sie wollen wir heute
in den Vordergrund stellen und Feiern
herzlich willkommen Kameraden
sehr geehrten und Festgäste ich biete
nun um ihren abschließenden aber umso
kräftigeren Applaus vielen Dank
[Applaus]
geschätzte Damen und Herren der
Kommandant der Heeres unkompliziert
Akademie Oberst des generalstabsdienstes
Magister klingenschmied wird nun seine
Worte an Sie richten und so viel darf
ich vorwegnehmen mit dem Wahlspruch der
hurg Enden welchen sie dann in
kameradschaftlicher Einheit von allen
hier angetretenen Wachtmeister
Geistlichkeit sehr geehrter general
geschätzte Gäste Angehörige und Partner
es ist mir eine Ehre Ihnen die Damen und
Herren Wachtmeister des
ausmusterungsjahrgangs 2023 vorzustellen
mit dem Abschluss der anspruchsvollen
unter dieses Grundausbildung der damit
einhergehenden Beförderung in den
Dienstgrad Wachtmeister und der Aufnahme
des unprofessierskorres österreichischen
Bundesheeres ist ein wesentlicher und
schöner Karriereschritt verbunden
als Kommandant der Heeres
unterversicherungsakademie bin ich stolz
auf das im Rahmen der
Ausbildungsorganisation gemeinsam
erzielten Ergebnisse und es war ein
Privileg einem ausgezeichneten Jahrgang
zu begleiten zu unterstützen und
hoffentlich zu beflügeln
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
Wachtmeister des Auslosung Jahrgang 2023
sie haben in den vergangenen Monaten
eine beeindruckende Reife Disziplin und
Beharrlichkeit gezeigt sie sind nicht
nur fachlich sondern auch persönlich
gewachsen sie haben nachgewiesen dass
sie mit die mit der Beförderung zum
Unteroffizier einhergehende hohe
Erwartungshaltung auch erfüllen können
damit sind alle Voraussetzungen für
einen erfolgreichen erfahrungsaufbau im
berufsvollzug in Verantwortung der hier
versammelten Kommandanten und Kommando
Unteroffiziere hergestellt
ich gratuliere Ihnen herzlich und
wünsche Ihnen viel Erfolg Erfüllung und
das notwendige Quäntchen Glück sie haben
einen facettenreichen lohnenden aber
auch anspruchsvollen Beruf gewählt
der heutige jahrestag der Eskalation des
Krieges in der Ukraine zeigte den aller
Deutlichkeit den Rahmen dieses
Anspruchsniveaus unsere politische
Führung hat bereits mit der
glaubwürdigen finanziellen Dotierung der
Landesverteidigung reagiert es wird
unsere gemeinsame Aufgabe sein die mit
dem Budget verbundene Erwartungshaltung
im Rahmen der Mission vorwärts auch zu
erfüllen
sie haben verstanden wie wichtig das
Wort gemeinsam ist unser Beruf fordert
in der Regel mehr von uns als einzelne
zu leisten vermögen wir sind deshalb
immer auf die Kameradinnen Kameraden
links und rechts von uns auf unsere
Vorgesetzten und auf die uns
anvertrauten Soldatinnen und Soldaten
angewiesen
erwerben unterhalten sie sich deren
vertrauten stellen Sie immer das
Verbinden der über das Trennende finden
Sie Lösungen statt Schuldigen und Sie
werden das Führungskraft erfolgreich
sein
erfüllen Sie Ihre Aufträge selbstständig
und gewissenhaft stellen Sie dabei das
Wohlergehen und die Moral der ihnen
anvertrauten Soldaten in einen Soldaten
immer an erster Stelle ergreifen sie
Initiative und führen Sie mutig und von
vorne lernen und entwickeln Sie sich
weiter sehen Sie den
akademie-symbol dafür dass sich diese
Aufwand immer lohnen wird
gehen Sie aktiv und unverzüglich gegen
Fehlentwicklung eine Bundesheer vor
schauen Sie nicht weg sondern hin und
stellen sie Unzulänglichkeiten nicht da
sondern ab
tragen Sie diese militärischen Jugend
ihr Wissen und ihre Erfahrungen als
gefestigte Persönlichkeiten auch in die
ziviles Umfeld suchen und finden Sie die
Balance in dem was sie sich selbst und
in dem was ihren Familien und Freunden
zumuten geben sie halt seien Sie
aufmerksam wohlwollend und fürsorglich
und bereiten sie sorgfältig den
Zeitpunkt vor ab dem der militärische
Auftrag Priorität haben muss weil die
Republik auf sie zählt
tun sie das wäre Kameradinnen und
Kameraden für unser Bundeswehr für
unsere Bevölkerung und unser Land
[Applaus]
und Festgäste ich darf zu
Militärgeistlichen Teil überleiten hören
Sie zuerst einen Choral
danach werden hier Militärdekan Magister
Stefan guggerel der militäroberkurat
Magister Gregor schwimmberski Herr
Militär Iman Kenan corbitsch und für die
alevitische Glaubensgemeinschaft Herr
Yüksel Bilgin ihre Gebete für die Jungen
und Offiziere sprechen
[Musik]
die Welt ist nicht genug
sagt ein bekanntes Titellied einer
Filmreihe die Ihnen vielleicht aus dem
Ethikunterricht noch bekannt ist
die Welt ist nicht genug
aber es ist der beste Platz um
anzufangen
wir haben Kriege in Afrika in Asien und
in Europa Menschen die gegeneinander
kämpfen
diese Welt ist noch nicht friedlich und
gerecht
aber sie können Werte Damen und Herren
Wachtmeister
ihren Beitrag dazu leisten
und da wir heute schon einmal den Blick
zum Himmel erhoben haben
wird die Militärseelsorge in all ihren
Fassungen versuchen sie für diese
wichtige Aufgabe für Österreich und für
die ganze Welt bestmöglich zu
unterstützen
Brüder und Schwestern betet mit mir
guter Gott
wir bitten dich für viele Männer und
junge Frauen
die hier stehen
und einen neuen Weg beginnen
lasse die vor ihnen liegende Wege als
gesegnete Wege erfahren
lass sie an den Orten an den sie ihren
Dienst versehen werden Kameradschaft
erleben und lass sie ältere Kameraden
begegnen
die ihnen ihre beruflichen Anfänge
leicht machen
wir bitten dich um Gesundheit und
Bewahrung in schwierigen Situationen
für die Familien der ausgemusterten
bitten wir dich
schenke ihnen die Gewissheit dass du auf
die Töchter und Söhne schaust
halte deine schützende Hand über ihre
Beziehungen auch wenn der Dienstort
weiter weg von zu Hause sein wird
wir denken auch an die Vorgesetzten und
bitten Dich schenke ihnen Besonnenheit
und Zugewandtheit zu den ihnen
anvertrauten jungen Menschen
für alle bitten wir um friedliche Zeiten
lass wenn Streit entsteht auch
Versöhnung möglich sein
uns alle lassen nie vergessen in welch
gesegneter Gegend dir deiner Welt wir
leben dürfen
Friede
sei mit uns allen Amen
mit dem Namen Gottes des Alabama ist das
barmherzigen Werte Kameraden
nicht nur materielle und soziale
Umstände machen einen Menschen aus
sondern auch seine Ideale er ist nicht
nur was er eigentlich ist sondern auch
was er sein kann und soll
die Aktivitäten der Menschen tragen
Gemeinschaft Charakter das heißt sie
sind auf die Zusammenarbeit ihre
Mitmenschen auch
Aufgabenteilung angewiesen ohne
Koordination Kooperation ohne vereinigte
Kräfte vermag er seine Bedürfnisse nicht
zu stillen nicht gleich sind die gute
Tat und die schlechte Tat heißt es im
Koran in diesem Sinne wünsche ich euch
viel Soldaten Glück und Gottes Segen
Armin
möge Segen der Propheten Adam Noah Moses
Jesus und Mohammed unseren heiligenallee
und der
zwölfteten über jedem von euch sein der
Schöpfer möge ihnen Kraft und Freizeit
geben bei den Aufgaben die sie zu
bewältigen haben mögen ihre eingesetzten
mitteleffektiv sein und zum Ziel führen
seit stets im friedlichen dass er mit
dem Glaubensweg sondern in Frieden mit
Gott in Frieden mit den Menschen
unabhängig von Rasse Glaube und Herkunft
und nicht zuletzt auch in Frieden mit
euch selbst die sprechende Zunge von uns
Daten vom heiligenallee und das
erhebende Gebete von dir
möge unsere Weg Begleiter sein die
göttliche Wahrheit segne uns allen HU
der ewigen Wahrheit
sehr geschätzte Damen und Herren liebe
Zuseherinnen und zu sehr beim Livestream
sie hören jetzt den traditionsmarsch der
jahresunteroffiziersakademie den
Friedrich Marsch im Anschluss spricht
der Bürgermeister der Stadt Enns der
Christian delea
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sehr geschätzte Frau Bundesminister sehr
geschätzter Herr Landtagsabgeordneter
Herr general geschätzte ehren und
Festgäste Liebe
wachtmeisterinnen und Wachtmeister
der diesjährige Tag erwachtmeister an
diesem ersten Jahrestag des russischen
Angriffs auf die Ukraine ist ein im
wahrsten Sinne des Wortes
bemerkenswerter Tag für Sie meine Damen
und Herren Wachtmeister für die Menschen
in der Ukraine in Europa und auch für
die geflüchteten die hier in Linz
leben mittlerweile die Stadt Enns und
das Militär sind schon seit langer Zeit
seit den Zeiten der Römer miteinander
verbunden als grenz- und garnisons statt
waren wir über viele Jahrhunderte
Standort mehrerer Kasernen und vieler
Truppenteile und so ist auch die
heeres-und-offiziersakademie
[Musik]
ein wichtiger Bestandteil unserer Stadt
die huak ist Ausbildungsstätte für
erfolgreiche Fach und Führungskräfte des
Bundesheeres die leistet einen
wesentlichen Beitrag dazu dass die Stadt
Enns über ihre Grenzen hinaus
bekannt ist und für uns stellt sie einen
unverzichtbaren Wirtschaftsfaktor da ist
ein fixer und wertvoller Bestandteil
der Tradition und der Geschichte der
ältesten Stadt Österreichs dies haben
wir auch in einem Partnerschaftsvertrag
dokumentiert und in dieser Partnerschaft
steht die Verbundenheit nicht nur am
Papier im Gegenteil sie wird von beiden
Seiten geliebt
das Aufgabengebiet des Bundesheeres hat
sich verändert es ist nicht einfacher im
Gegenteil es ist viel größer komplexer
schwieriger geworden
die Soldaten nennen und Soldaten stehen
heute mit ihrem ganzen Einsatz für
Frieden zu erhaltende und humanitäre
Einsätze und wir haben Sie als Partner
gegen die Bedrohungen der Zukunft an
unserer Seite nicht nur im
Katastropheneinsatz leisten sie oft
wirklich unglaubliches neue
Bedrohungsszenarien wie beispielsweise
Blackouts oder Cyberangriffe Stellen
nicht minder große Herausforderungen da
und diesen neuen Herausforderungen wurde
und wird auch laufend die Ausbildung an
der Burg angepasst
die oberste Prämisse des
österreichischen Bundesheeres ist für
mich aber immer die Sicherung des
Friedens der Schutz der Demokratie und
der Menschenrechte und dafür möchte ich
mich bei Ihnen allen ganz herzlich
bedanken
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
Wachtmeister ihnen kommt künftig eine
Schlüsselrolle bei der Ausbildung der
Rekruten zu und sie übernehmen damit
auch eine enorme Verantwortung setzen
Sie das hier an der huak Enns gelernte
als Führungskräfte des österreichischen
Bundesheers um
ich freue mich wenn Sie unsere Stadt
nicht nur in guter Erinnerung behalten
sondern auch des öfteren wieder besuchen
ich wünsche Ihnen für Ihren weiteren
Lebensweg und ihre künftige Laufbahn
alles Gute viel Erfolg herzlichen Dank
und alles Gute nochmals bei der
Erfüllung ihrer Aufgaben dankeschön
[Applaus]
geschätzte
sie hören jetzt die großworte des Landes
Oberösterreich es spricht der
Abgeordnete zum Oberösterreichischen
Landtag Herr Wolfgang Stanek daran
anschließend folgt der Marsch der
Gesellschaft
sehr geehrte Frau Bundesministerin
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
Wachtmeister sehr geehrte Ehrengäste
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
im Jahr 62 nach Christus schrieb der
römische Philosoph senegger an einem
Brieffreund
folgenden Satz
nicht für das Leben sondern für die
Schule lernen wir
jetzt werden sich wahrscheinlich manche
von ihnen sagen Moment einmal das müsste
doch genau umgekehrt heißen aber er hat
es tatsächlich so geschrieben weil er
mit seinen Worten damals die Zustände in
den philosophischen Schulen Roms
kritisieren wollte das zu wenig bei der
Ausbildung auf das Leben Bedacht
genommen wird
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
Wachtmeister ich gratuliere Ihnen in
erster Linie auch dazu dass er sich zu
dieser Ausbildung an deren Ende sie
heute stehen entschieden haben weil es
eine Ausbildung ist wo sie tatsächlich
für ihr Leben
ungeheuer viel gelernt haben
sowohl für ihr Berufsleben als auch für
ihr Privatleben ich danke Ihnen aber
auch ganz ganz herzlich im Namen des
Landes Oberösterreich für ihre
Bereitschaft ganz wesentlich für die
Sicherheit in unserem Land beizutragen
Sicherheit
ein Wort das in den letzten Jahren und
vor allem im letzten Jahr auch im
Bewusstsein unserer Bevölkerung eine
neue und ganz wesentliche Bedeutung
bekommen hat
jeder Mensch in unserem Land jeder
Mensch auf der Welt
strebt nach Sicherheit
Menschen brauchen die Sicherheit aber
wir dürfen eines nie vergessen
Sicherheit braucht auch Menschen
Menschen die bereit sind sich zu
engagieren Menschen die bereit sind
andere Menschen zu schützen das tun sie
in ihrem Beruf und auch dafür ist Ihnen
in einem ganz besonderen Ausmaß zu
danken
wenn ich gesagt habe Sicherheit braucht
auch Menschen dann braucht Sicherheit
aber auch mehr mehr Ressourcen und es
ist mir wirklich ein besonderes Anliegen
mich bei dir liebe Frau Bundesministerin
ganz besonders dafür zu bedanken dass du
in deiner Tätigkeit als verantwortliche
Ministerin gerade jetzt auch ganz
wesentlich dazu beigetragen hast dass
den Bundesheer in Zukunft wesentlich
mehr auch Geldmittel zur Verfügung
stehen das ist gerade in Zeiten wie
jetzt bei Gott nicht selbstverständlich
aber es ist auch ganz besonders wichtig
für die Sicherheit in unserem Land und
für die Sicherheit der Menschen in
unserem Land
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
Wachtmeister ich wünsche Ihnen für Ihre
persönliche Zukunft ich wünsche Ihnen
für Ihre berufliche Zukunft
weiterhin viel Freude ich wünsche Ihnen
viel Energie ich wünsche Ihnen viel
Erfolg und uns allen eine friedvolle
Zukunft
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren ist Erfolg
nun stellvertretend für alle Absolventen
die Beförderung der vier
lehrgangssprecher der Frauenbeauftragten
sowie des Vertreters der
militium-offiziere
Abordnungen und lehrgangsbester
vortreten
ich bitte jetzt die Frau
Bundesministerin den Herrn
Landtagsabgeordneten den Chef des
Generalstabs die akademiekommandanten
und den kommandunterfiziert der Akademie
die Ehrungen und Beförderungen
vorzunehmen
Abordnungen eintreten
geschätzte Damen und Herren an den
lehrgangsbesten des lehrgangszugsführer
Franz Lippert wird das Ehrengeschenk der
goldene Ring der
jahresunteroffiziersakademie durch die
Frau Bundesministerin überreicht
lehrgangsbester ist erwachtmeister
Marcel Burger
er hat bei den dienstprüfungen
ausgezeichnete Leistungen in sieben
Gegenständen erreicht
Wachtmeister Burger wird Dienst als
pioniergruppen-
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren wir haben
für Sie eine Videobotschaft vorbereitet
in der sich Kommandanten und Vertreter
der Brigaden und Bataillone des
Bundesheeres mit Grußworten an ihre
Jungen Wachtmeister und an uns richten
werden
liebe Kameraden wir wünschen euch alles
Gute für die Hoffnung 2023 besonders den
Unteroffizieren des 20-Jährige
Bataillons 35
servus gratulation zum motorisierer
dürfen denn den letzten 18 Monaten der
unkomplizierten Grundausbildung
sozusagen hautnah und mitten im
Geschehen war den lehrgangsbesten der
sechsten kardanwärtnerbildung 3 Herrn
Wachtmeister Marcel Burger nach seiner
Ansprache hören Sie das Musikstück
kastaldomage
sehr geehrte Frau Bundesministerin werde
Ehrengäste Werte Angehörige und vor
allem wertekameraden wir stehen alle
hier um die diesjährige Ausmusterung der
Unteroffiziere zu feiern nach den
fordernden aber auch fördernden drei
Teilen der kardanwärterausbildung stehen
wir heute hier und tragen ab heute den
Dienstgrad Wachtmeister für mich ist der
Dienstgrad aber nicht nur ein Dienstgrad
wissen ist Macht im Laufe der Ausbildung
haben wir alle viel gelernt sei es durch
praktische oder theoretische Ausbildung
wir haben viel über uns selbst gelernt
aber vor allem auch über andere
es liegt an jedem selbst wir diese Macht
nutzt und sein Wissen einsetzt
für mich haben im Laufe der Ausbildung
drei Worte sehr an Wert gewonnen
Kameradschaft Selbstdisziplin und
Ehrlichkeit auf das erste dieser drei
Grundprinzipien will ich nun näher
eingehen Kameradschaft
in den letzten 18 Monaten wurden wir an
unsere Grenzen geführt manchmal
psychisch oft aber auch physisch
das macht uns Unteroffiziere aus wir
sind körperlich so wie geistig zur
höchsten Leistungen fähig zu jeder Zeit
wir haben uns verpflichtet unseren
Vaterland und dem österreichischen
Volkes zu dienen es muss jedem bewusst
sein dass dies im schlimmsten Fall heißt
sein Leben zu geben um andere zu retten
Franz Lippert hat das Zugführer mit
seiner Bürger eine Brücke die sie selbst
errichtet haben bei den Ortschaften
obwohl sie Verluste erlitten entschloss
Lippert weiter die Brücke zu halten um
österreichischen Truppen die Rückkehr zu
gewährleisten
als die Dämmerung anbrach erhöhten die
russischen Truppen das Feuer die braven
saböre schätten jedoch keine Gefahr um
den einzigen Übergang der eigenen Truppe
zu sichern
dieses Gedankengut können wir auch auf
unsere Zeit übertragen
beispielhaft eigentlich mich an den an
unsere Abschlussübung der
kardanwärterausbildung 3 für einige
Kameraden sind der abschlussmarsch nach
harten Tagen und Nächten als
Gruppenkommandant als unüberwindbarer
Fluss
besprachen innerhalb der Gruppe und es
gab Kameraden
die keine Brücke über diesen Fluss sahen
als wir doch weg marschierten spürte man
den Ehrgeiz jedes Einzelnen
auch von jenen Kameraden die selbst
Zweifel hatten
es schien als hätte nun jeder meiner
Gruppe eine Brücke über den eins zu
unüberwindbaren Fluss jedoch leider wie
so jeder Marsch forderte auch dieses
eine Opfer vom Blasen über die ganze
Fußsohle bis über Schultern die
Schmerzen war alles dabei aufgrund
dieser schwernisse droht dabei einigen
die eben errichtete Brücke zu bröckeln
und einzustürzen
es war genau diese Momente in denen wir
lernten wie wichtig Kameradschaft ist
durch die physische und psychische
Leistungsfähigkeit den der Gruppe
vorhanden war konnten wir einst wie
liefert die Brücke und somit den
einzigen Übergang sicherstellen indem
wir uns gegenseitig unterstützen
wir alle haben es über die Brücke
geschafft und den abschlussmarsch
positiv absolviert selbst unüberwindbare
Hindernisse im Leben sei es dienstlich
oder privat
kann man mit genug Unterstützung
bewältigen dabei kommt es weder auf die
Herkunft auf das Geschlecht oder die
Religionen wichtig ist nur die richtige
Einstellung
in diesem Sinne möchte Danke sagen an
Wachtmeister
Ebner Alexander Wachtmeister Rudig
Nicola und Wachtmeister
diese Herren haben wir privat und
dienstlich sehr unterstützt
sowie an das ganze
ausbildungskader der gesamten
lehrkomponie sowie des Institut eins der
Heeres unteroffiziersakademie
halten
erinnern Sie sich jeden Tag warum sie
Unteroffizier geworden sind und welche
Verantwortung damit einhergeht
ich bin mir sicher dass dieser Jahrgang
die Zukunft des österreichischen
Bundesheers prägen wird und positive
Veränderungen bringt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Damen und Herren Werte Zuseher zu Hause
vor dem Bildschirmen hören Sie nun die
Ansprache des ranghöchsten Offiziers im
Bundesheer den Chef des Generalstabs wir
haben general Magister Rudolf
Striedinger
daran anschließend folgt das Musikstück
hoch in Österreich
Frau Bundesministerin
sehr geehrter Herr Abgeordneter
Bürgermeister sehr geehrte ehren- und
Festgäste sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
sehr geehrte Kommando und Offiziere und
mit ihnen
insbesondere sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren Wachtmeister
ich freue mich dass heute so viel
Persönlichkeiten hier auf diesen
Stadtplatz in Enns gefunden haben und
möchte über die bereits erwähnten noch
drei Personen anführen über deren
Anwesenheit ich mich besonders freue
nämlich den Kommandanten der
versorgungsgruppen des Bundesheeres
generalmaier magist alexanderplatzer die
Heeres sanitätschefin des Bundesheeres
bringt der Doktor
und den stellvertretenden
der Bürgermeister hat das erwähnt hat
ist ein besonderer Tag
sie haben heute eine Ausbildung
abgeschlossen
eine Ausbildung die während einer
besonderen Zeit stattgefunden hat
während einer Pandemie
während einer Zeit in der das Bundesheer
extrem herausgefordert war in
unterschiedlichsten Einsätzen der
österreichischen Bevölkerung zu helfen
in einer Zeit in der ein Krieg begonnen
hat in Europa
in eine Zeit werden es jetzt kommen wo
das Bundesheer gerade sieht dringend
benötigt
weil wir durch die Politik Budgetmittel
zur Verfügung gestellt bekommen haben
die uns in den nächsten zehn Jahren das
österreichische Bundesheer wieder
aufbauen lassen können
und sie sind ein ganz wertvoller und
wesentlicher Bestandteil davon ich
bedanke mich daher bei Ihnen allen dass
sie die Entscheidung getroffen haben auf
der einen Seite diesen Beruf zu
ergreifen und sich diese Ausbildung zu
stellen
auf der anderen Seite bedanke ich mich
bei den Wachtmeister der Miliz dass sie
das auf sich genommen haben und dass sie
unseren Einsatzbereitschaft des
Bundesheeres entsprechend verstärken
können
und ich gratuliere allen Ihnen dazu dass
Sie diese Ausbildung so
bewältigt haben
Kameradschaft gelernt haben
fachliches gelernt haben und wissen wie
sie mit Menschen umzugehen haben
diese Ausbildung wurde sichergestellt
durch eine
wertvollsten Ausbildungseinrichtungen
die wir haben daher ist und
offiziersakademie
unterstützt durch eine Vielzahl von
Gruppen und Dienststellen des
österreichischen Bundesheeres
insbesondere der Schulorganisation dafür
allen von meiner Seite eine herzliches
Dankeschön
der bereits angesprochene Aufbauplan des
Bundesheeres
führt uns in eine hoffentlich gute
Zukunft des Bundesheeres ein
entscheidender Punkt daran ist jedoch
die personelle Entwicklung wie wir alle
wissen
und gerade sie
Damen und Herren Wachtmeister sind an
einer ganz entscheidenden Position wenn
es darum geht
mit Menschen mit Grundwehrdienern die
ihnen über der antwortet werden mit
Frauen im Ausbildungsdienst diese
ausbilden sollen
umzugehen und ich möchte
die Worte des Kommandanten der Heeres
und offiziersakademie bei weitem nicht
wiederholen aber unterstreichen
dass sie Menschenführer sind
sie müssen mit unseren jungen
österreichischen Staatsbürgern so
umgehen dass diese sich wertgeschätzt
fühlen und dass sie gegebenenfalls auch
Interesse am Soldatenberuf gewinnen sei
es als Berufssoldatin Berufssoldat sei
es für die Miliz
und daher fordere ich Sie auf
nehmen Sie Ihre persönlichen Fähigkeiten
und sind Sie richtige Menschenführer wir
brauchen das
das Fachliche wurde in den mitgegeben
aber das persönliche muss von ihnen
kommen in diesem Sinne lebe der Jahrgang
Zugführer Franz Lippert es lebe die
Heeres und offiziersakademie es lebe das
österreichische Bundesheer danke
[Applaus]
[Musik]
eine große Auszeichnung für unsere
Ausbildungsstätte und das unkompliziert
Score insgesamt ist die Anwesenheit
unserer Frau Bundesministerin Frau
Minister Claudia
hohe militärgeistlichkeit
sehr geehrter Herr Abgeordneter in
Vertretung für unseren Landeshauptmann
sehr geehrter Herr generalstoffchef
sehr geehrter Herr Bürgermeister ja
militzbeauftragter
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident der
undoffiziersgesellschaft
Offiziersgesellschaft Hohe Vertreter der
Personalvertretung sehr geehrte
Ehrengäste
vor allem aber
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
Wachtmeister
heute
genau heute vor einem Jahr am 24
Februar 2022
mit dem Angriff Putins auf die Ukraine
für die europäische und österreichische
Sicherheitspolitik
der Krieg
ist wieder nach Europa zurückgekehrt
auch bei uns ist Friede keine
Selbstverständlichkeit mehr
das war mitunter auch der Grund
warum ich im Vorjahr bei der
Ausmusterung der 25
Februar nicht dabei sein konnte
obwohl es doch geplant war
stattdessen
nahm ich an der Sitzung des nationalen
Sicherheitsrates Teil die kurz nach dem
Angriff Russlands sehr rasch einberufen
wurde
heuer ist die Situation eine andere
als
Verteidigungsministerin sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren ist es mir wichtig
den Soldatinnen und Soldaten nahe zu
sein
denen die aktuell und in der Zukunft
für unsere Landesverteidigung und für
unser aller Sicherheit sorgen
und es war eine ganz bewusste
Entscheidung dass ich heute nicht bei
der Sondersitzung des Parlaments mit
dabei bin sondern hier
hier bei der Ausrüstung der
Unteroffiziere am Tag der Wachtmeister
die Unteroffiziere sind ein wesentlicher
Bestandteil einer funktionierenden Armee
das zeigt sich schon oft in der
Geschichte des Militärs
Kameradschaft
Tapferkeit und
Standhaftigkeit in lebensgefährlichen
Situationen mit diesen Eigenschaften hat
es sich der Soldat Franz Lipper dem
Ersten Weltkrieg mehrfach bewährt und
wurde auch 1915 mit der goldenen
Tapferkeitsmedaille
ausgezeichnet ich gratuliere auch dem
Jahrgangsbesten
Wachtmeister Burger für diese
Darstellung die in seiner Rede gebracht
hat
die Soldatinnen und Soldaten des
Lehrgangs der heute ausgemustert wird
haben sich genau diese Eigenschaften als
ihr persönliches Vorbild ausgewählt es
sind Eigenschaften die eigentlich auch
heute noch
mehr als ein Jahrhundert später für das
gesamte unprofiziers Chor als Vorbild
gelten sollten
da freue ich mich
dass sie als junge aber doch schon sehr
erfahrene Soldatinnen und Soldaten die
es auch so sehen
es wurde halt schon einiges angesprochen
worden die vielen Krisen
in denen wir uns befinden denen wir
entgegen sehen und dennoch sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren ich persönlich und ich
glaube auch wir als österreichisches
Bundesheer können dazukunft sehr wohl
positiv entgegen sehen daher
Landtagsabgeordnete hat schon
angesprochen und auch unser
Generalstabschef mit dem Bundesheer geht
es wieder bergauf wir haben das höchste
landesverteidigungsbudget der Geschichte
16 Milliarden Euro in den kommenden vier
Jahren die uns die Möglichkeit geben und
auch die Verpflichtung dass wir unser
Bundesheer zu einem modernen her
aufstellen das geeignet ist den
Anforderungen den Bedrohungsszenarien
des 21
jahrhunderts begegnen zu können vor
allem aber seine Aufgaben erfüllen zu
können
Schutz und zur Sicherheit der
Bevölkerung wir tun das mit der Mission
vorwärts mit der Beschaffung von
Ausrüstung Waffen und Gerät genauso wie
mit attraktiven Maßnahmen für unser
Personal erst gestern konnten wir
gemeinsam in großmittel die neuen
Investitionen bei der mechanisierten
Truppe vorstellen ein
Investitionsvolumen von 560 Millionen
Euro bis zum Jahr 2029 insgesamt 170
gepanzerte Fahrzeuge die modernisiert
werden davon 58
Kampfpanzer Leopard 2 A4 112
Schützenpanzer olan das ist nach dem
großen
Investitionspaket zur Beschaffung von 36
Hubschraubern des Typs Leonardo 73
Millionen Euro der nächste große und
wichtige Schritt zu einem modernen Heer
und wir müssen auch in die Infrastruktur
investieren in unsere Kasernen in ganz
Österreich
Generalsanierungen Ausbauten wir müssen
unsere Kasernen auf Vordermann bringen
und diese autark machen
dieser zehnjährige
Aufbauplan ist unglaublich wichtig für
Beschaffungen für Modernisierungen und
ich nehme den Dank schon ganz gerne
entgegen für das Budget das dem
österreichischen Bundesheer zur
Verfügung stellt ich will Ihnen aber
gleichzeitig auch weitergeben
weitergeben an alle politischen Parteien
die im Parlament dafür gesorgt haben
dass man erkannt hat dass militärische
Sicherheit dass allerwichtigste ist dass
wir nicht wie in der Vergangenheit die
soziale Sicherheit gegen die
militärische
ausspielen dass man erkannt hat dass
Sicherheit vielleicht nicht alles ist
aber ohne Sicherheit sehr geehrte Damen
und Herren wohl alles nichts ist
das eine sind die Beschaffungen und das
Budget das andere sind aber die Menschen
das sind unsere Soldatinnen und Soldaten
die auch eines tun müssen wieder mehr
üben müssen um
zielgerecht und abgestimmt ihre Aufgaben
auch erfüllen zu können und daher habe
ich vor einigen Monaten angewiesen dass
wir 20 24 eine große Übung mit den Namen
Schutzschild 24 durchführen werden das
Thema ist eine schutzoperation das Ziel
dieser Übung ist die militärischen
Kernfähigkeiten der Soldatinnen und
Soldaten durch praktische Anwendung auf
der gefechtstechnischen und taktischen
Ebene zu festigen und außerdem die
Einsatzbereitschaft der Streitkräfte zu
evaluieren und weiter zu entwickeln
diese Großübung die umfasst alle
Waffengattungen einschließlich der
Luftstrecke und natürlich der Miliz sie
findet den drei Bundesländern statt in
Niederösterreich Steiermark und Kärnten
es wird in der Masse im freien Gelände
geübt werden was auch die Präsenz des
Bundesheeres in der Öffentlichkeit
bestärkt das ist ein so wichtiger Punkt
und daher ist auch der heutige Akt
dieser heutige Tag ein ganz wichtiger wo
wir inmitten der Öffentlichkeit sein
dürfen die Hauptaufgabe sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren die militärische
Landesverteidigung die muss wieder in
den Mittelpunkt in den Vordergrund
gerückt werden
heute ist ein großer Tag heute ist ein
großer Tag vor allem für Sie
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
Wachtmeister aber auch ein großer Tag
für uns alle sie
erleben die Beförderung zum Wachtmeister
das ist ein bedeutender Schritt in ihrer
Karriere sowie auch schon angesprochen
worden ist vom Kommandanten der hoag er
ist ein wichtiger Schritt weil sie
erfolgreich die Ausbildung zum
Unteroffizier abgeschlossen haben es ist
aber auch ein ganz großer Tag für uns
alle weil wir heute mit den 356
Wachtmeister des Präsenz und
militstandes weitere neue Damen und
Herren Unteroffiziere im Bundesheer
willkommen heißen dürfen ich gratuliere
Ihnen allen zu ihren absolvierten
Leistungen
Soldatinnen Soldaten sie haben
monatelang ihre Ausbildung zur
Führungskraft absolviert sie tragen
jetzt den Dienstgrad Wachtmeister sie
sind von nun an einem Bindeglied
zwischen den Offizieren und den
Mannschaften sie arbeiten als Kommandant
Ausbilder Erzieher oder sie gehen
möglicherweise als Wachtmeister der
Miliz in den
Auslandseinsatz aber ganz egal wo sie
zum Einsatz kommen von ihnen wird
Engagement Flexibilität
Mobilität und Professionalität gefordert
bei der Arbeit im Inland genauso wie in
Auslandseinsätzen
seien sie ein Vorbild seien sie ein
Vorbild für andere besonders dann wenn
sie mit Grundwehrdienern zu tun haben
sie dürfen niemals darauf vergessen dass
diese die Grundwehrdiener das Bundesheer
in erster Linie über sie wahrnehmen und
erleben Sie werden mitunter die wohl
wichtigste dienstliche Bezugsperson sein
für die jungen Männer und Frauen im
Grundwehrdienst und im Ausbildungsdienst
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren und
Offiziere ich bedanke mich für ihre
Einsatzbereitschaft ich möchte an dieser
Stelle aber auch ein ganz großes
Dankeschön sagen an ihre Angehörigen an
ihre Freunde an ihre Familie die sie auf
diesem Weg unterstützt haben auf diesem
Weg der ja nichts anderes ist als den
Schutz des Staates Österreich
sicherzustellen seiner Bevölkerung den
Schutz unserer Neutralität den Schutz
von uns allen dafür ist unser Bundesheer
die Sicherheitsgarantie und sie sie sind
ein wesentlicher ein wichtiger Teil
davon sehr geehrte Herren und Frauen
Wachtmeister sie muss dann jetzt zu
ihren Verbänden aus und werden diese mit
ihrer Arbeit wesentlich unterstützen nun
können Sie zeigen nun können sie
anwenden was sie gelernt haben und Sie
können insbesondere auch ihre
Führungsstärke beweisen ich nein wir
alle wünschen Ihnen dabei alles Gute
viel Erfolg und viel Soldaten Glück es
lebe die Heeres und offiziersakademie es
lebe das österreichische Bundesheer es
lebe die Republik Österreich
[Applaus]
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
nach den wertschätzenden und
erwartungsvollen Worten der
höchstrangigen Vertreters Politik und
Militär nehmen wir uns langsam dem Ende
der offiziellen Feier
eingeleitet wird dieses durch die
Europahymne oder an die Freude dazu
bitte ich Sie sich von den Plätzen zu
erheben
das ganze
[Musik]
ich bitte Sie noch einmal Platz zu
nehmen
der
kommandantschlager wird in Kürze der
Frau Bundesministerin melden und um
weitere Befehle bitten davor erlaube ich
mir noch ein paar Informationen zum
weiteren Ablauf des Festtags zu geben
nach dem Ausmarsch der Ehrenformation
und dem Militärmusik endet der Festakt
hier am Mensa Stadtplatz
sehr geehrte Herren und Festgäste sie
sind im Anschluss sehr herzlich zum
Empfang im Wirtschaftsgebäude am Campus
der doberer eingeladen
geschätzte Damen und Herren Wachtmeister
sie dürfen unmittelbar nach Beendigung
des großen Festaktes abtreten und sind
dann in unser Bundesheer und seine
Einheiten entlassen wo ich Ihnen
persönlich vor allem die Freude am
Soldatenberuf Wünsche die ich seit
vielen Jahren erleben darf
davor soll aber Ihnen an Ihrem großen
Ehrentag die weitere Gestaltung des
seligen mit ihren hoffentlich Anwesenden
Familien Bekannten und Freunden
ermöglicht werden
meine Damen und Herren Werte
Zuseherinnen und Zuseher bei der
Live-Übertragung ich bedanke mich sehr
herzlich für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit und ihr
Interesse am heutigen Tag der
Wachtmeister auf Wiedersehen in ens auf
Wiedersehen an der Burg
[Applaus]
zur Meldung an die Frau Bundesminister
das ganze hey
S
und bittet um weitere Befehle
abrücken Damen und Herren Wachtmeister
abtreten lassen
das ganze
halb acht
Hering wohl
zum Ausmarsch der Insignien der Heeres
und offiziersakademie das ganze recht
schaut
[Musik]
das ganze
Ehre Komponist
das ganze Parade gut Konrad
ehrenkomponie übernehmen Ehrenformation
abrücken
Jahrgang 2023 habt oft
[Musik]